en ile-de-france il était célèbre pour
avoir réalisé les espaces abraxas à
noisy-le-grand la place des colonnes à
cergy pontoise ou encore la place de
catalogne à paris ricardo beau fils est
mort le 14 janvier à l'âge de 82 ans
emporté par le cos vite 19 dans les
yvelines il était connu pour être le
concepteur des arcades du lac au sein du
quartier de lasours de riz à montigny le
bretonneux réalisé de 1978 à 1982
l'ensemble architectural est surnommé le
versailles du peuple ça touche un peu
comme tout le monde dit que celles de
versailles le peuple
en moi ici tout le monde peut venir y
prendre un pique nique y discuter un peu
faire son sport qu'il s'est vraiment
service plus déçu qu'il soit si vite
mais bon on va le fait qu'on en parle
déjà c'est à dire qu' il va rester un
petit peu dans l'histoire déjà je dirais
que c'est
un quartier qui possède une architecture
très spécial
qui a tendance à ressembler au château
de versailles c'est ce que voulait
d'architecte il me semble et ce qui est
très bien c'est que c'est beaucoup
visité c'est très agréable à vivre c'est
très calme avec la pièce d'eau à côté il
y en a plein d'oiseaux migrateurs c'est
un quartier très calme très familial en
fait on al'avantage que ce soit
complètement piétons donc du coup pour
les enfants c'est idéal l'architecte
novateur aimé réaliser l'impossible il a
construit 380 logements sur le bassin de
la sourderie le site devient
emblématique dans les années 80 il ya
beaucoup de grands noms qui sont de l'
architecture qui sont associés à saint
quentin en yvelines
ricardo bofill fait partie de ces grands
noms c'est aussi une fierté donc dans le
sens où c'est la première grande
réalisation de beaux fils
en france et fait un ensemble qui a
toujours été emblématique quatre ans
plus tard et cardo beau fils a complété
son oeuvre avec la construction de 200
logements baptisé les temples est
emplettes ce nouveau quartier est situé
de l'autre côté du lac à voisins le
bretonneux ces lieux ont inspiré de
nombreux artistes comme nekfeu soprano
et niño qui va enregistrer leurs clips
[Musique]